that's kind of what you need to do with
your evening news or your fox news you
watch CNN for the Democrats you watch
Fox for the Republicans and if you watch
both way I put you two freaking rubber
room you're gonna lose your mind hey
guys everybody's talking about it out
there everybody's nobody the news media
is talking about it
regular people are just going to work
but there's a lot of yakking going on
and so I'm getting some stuff on social
media Davers there gonna be a recession
the Democrats that desperately want a
recession because it would help them
elect a president because if Trump is
successful economically the Democrats
are screwed is there gonna be a
recession if I'm a Democrat I sure hope
so if I'm a Republican I sure hope not
Oh yep yep yep yep yak yak yak yak
listen weather forecasters and
economists are the only people can be
wrong all the time and keep their jobs
okay so here's the thing if the GDP the
gross domestic product which is the
number that represents all the goods and
services produced in the American
economy the US economy if it is
infalling mode if it shrinks the size of
the economy shrinks recedes for two
consecutive quarters we call that a
recession that's what a recession is
it's not the boogeyman is going to come
to your house and take your children
it's two quarters six months that the
economy shrunk as a whole instead of
grew as a whole so really it's not the
end of the frickin world what matters is
what's happening at your house now if
the economy continues to shrink
instead of continues to grow that's not
good because people start to lose jobs
because companies don't have income
they're not selling goods and services
so they don't need people to produce the
goods or services and the job market
tends to shrink but for the first time
in economic history right now
we have negative unemployment now the
stats aren't showing that but the real
world out there is there are more jobs
than people looking for them right now
and so it could shrink a good bit and
still be very vibrant now I was a Donald
Trump I listen and it's singing to
Donald Trump let me just tell you the
people in the White House do not cause
the economy to happen you people out
there in America cause the economy to
happen when you come up with great new
ideas and create new things and sell new
things and make new things and make
great things and cut great hair and run
a great restaurant and make great shoes
you are the economy Donald Trump is not
the economy Barack Obama is not the
economy and you can't blame the economy
on Ronald Reagan george w bush because
it's very hard to find that you can
actually tie all the government things
that they don't do because they don't do
much they just sit up there and [ __ ]
all the time but the things that they
don't do to the actual economy however
it does swing elections famous words out
of George Bush's mouth it's the
economy's you know it's the economy
stupid right
it's a it get caught up with him right
so you know they do swing does swing
elections but the interesting part of
that is is that's because people
actually believe what they do up there
matters what you do is what you do at
your house matters a whole lot more than
what happens at the White House so I
don't know if the GDP is going to shrink
for two consecutive quarters it would
have to do it for one consecutive
quarter first and it hasn't done that
yet and so it will be at least six
months before we see this now and so but
economists economists economists yeah I
know but let me just tell you they shut
the schools down here because they
thought there might be a thunderstorm
that didn't come you know I mean this is
the world we live in today the would
suffocation of America and so the deal
is very
simple if you will do the stuff I'm
teaching gods and grandmas ways of
handling money called common sense you
will prosper in good times economically
and you will prosper in down times
economically if you go to work and tell
the truth and work hard while you're at
work and smile while you're at work and
don't be nasty to people while you're at
work and be good to the customer while
you're at work
you'll have a job because most people
can't even show up and do that they
forget to work while they're at work
they're too busy checking their freakin
Facebook account instead of actually
working so here's a plan you're gonna be
ok if you actually work here you're
gonna be ok if you actually have an
emergency fund you're gonna be ok if you
actually have investments you're gonna
be ok if you don't have any debt you're
gonna be ok if you live on a budget
you're gonna be ok so turn off FoxNews
nobody watching CNN anywhere I tell you
to turn them off
dadgum ratings are in the back in the
tank I'll tell you I mean turn office
the the the ABC Evening News I don't
even know who the guy is I haven't
watched him in years or is a girl now I
don't even know the only time I watch
one of those things is if one of the
rims you personalities are on it
I don't even turn on the stupid
television Zig Ziglar used to say I get
up every morning I read the newspaper
and read the Bible because I can tell
what both sides are doing that's kind of
what you need to do with your evening
news or your fox news you watch CNN for
the Democrats you watch Fox for the
Republicans and if you watch both where
I put you in a freaking rubber room you
lose your mind
so much propaganda you choke on it it's
unbelievable
it's the state-run networks it's
ridiculous they haven't had an original
thought in years and you sit around
you're gonna decide you're gonna sit
around decide if you're in a good mood
or if there's a recession coming based
on that crap don't do that just do your
deal what happens at your house is there
a recession at your house have you had
two consecutive Co downturns who can say
of quarters of downturn at your house
you know what caused that it wasn't a
White House it was you have you had two
consecutive upturns
are you in a bull market you know what
caused that it was you I made money
under liberals I made and lost money
under conservatives I made and lost
money under liberals turns out that I
was the variable not the character that
some of you thought was gonna bring you
prosperity they're not gonna bring you
prosperity they lied it's not in their
power to give you prosperity they lied
your Congressman your senator your
governor I did this for the economy
horse crap you did nothing you're a
politician you're not a producer of
anything you guys out there listening to
me of the producers so get about the
business of not having a recession at
your house whether or not we choose to
have one in the US as a result of
self-fulfilling prophecy of cable news